[Applauso]
[Musica]
hermes mangialardo
allora hermes io tu la tua biografia ho
letto queste cose classe 1975 cresciuto
a pane tex willer e mazinga z a 14 anni
vedi film the wall e decidi cosa farai
da grande
oggi sei cartoonist videomaker visual
performer dal 2003 ti occupi di tutto
ciò che ruota intorno all'animazione
digitale
prendi premi ovunque da amburgo agli
stati uniti da barcellona al giffoni
film festival
i tuoi corti ei tuoi video clip sono
stati premiati nei maggiori festival
dedicati all'animazione digitale
allora diciamo tu avevi un tema come la
memoria un teatro antico e aiutata
l'animazione digitale come si tiene
insieme tutto questo in un video mapping
bellissimo come quello che abbiamo
appena visto
grazie grazie è stata una bella
occasione fare video mapping oltre che
una bella sfida fare un video mapping
all'interno di un teatro dove ovviamente
non ci sono strutture architettoniche
importanti se non costruite sul palco
delle scenografie abbiamo voluto in un
certo modo ribaltare il punto di vista e
abbiamo fatto nel punto in cui nessuno
guarda il soffitto
quindi mi scuso per il torcicollo e
sicuramente farà venuto a qualcuno però
è stata una sfida anche per il
proiettore messo in mezzo a una strada
che mi sta in verticale quindi soffre
molto diciamo le temperature in questo
in questo senso e quindi anche a livello
tecnico è stata anche una sfida non
sapevamo fino all'ultimo se si andava in
porto o meno a livello di
dite ma è l'architettura secondo me è la
memoria quando di pari passo e basta
citare palmira ad esempio per cui
diciamo non è solo quello che vediamo è
anche quello che i monumenti ci
raccontano anche quando non ci sono più
faccio l'esempio di palmira ma se
vogliamo andare su qualcosa di più le
nostre terre e il regina pacis in cui
abbiamo fatto insieme a mario perrotta
uno spettacolo con un video mapping e
adesso quell'edificio non c'è più in
qualche modo d'arte digitale ecco cioè
serve anche a ricostruire ricordare
qualcosa
ok perfetto grazie hermes mangialardo